have with a child if it would stop a nuclear bomb from exploding
in New York. Would you? Now, if you think that's cool and in
the context of everything else of him continually and trying
to normalized
activity with minors, he has he's been doing this over the span
of his entire career. If you think that is fine and holding on
to potential child is fine, then go ahead and defend Destiny.
You're sweeping for a what looks to me to be a
long-term, highly motivated, premeditated child predator. Show
you guys a few. >> Around the end of 2011, Destiny assaulted
a woman on his live stream. I'm not using the word allegedly
here because we have video of him doing it and he has openly
admitted that it was
I've got a couple tweets that I was going to go over real quick.
Okay, got fresh wick copium over here. There's some fresh wick
copium. Hold on.
>> Let's check this out. Here's the thing. >> And
it's going to sound weird.
You can judge me if you like. >> I'll be honest. I I have
no understanding of what the the comment would be there given
like some of the wick tweets we saw the other day. I have no
idea what the comment would be here. Okay. What could it possibly
be? >> But I think if I had been friends with Destiny,
like actual friends and not just someone who talks to him every
once in a while, right, in a professional setting, right? If
I had been friends, he would not have done this because he would
have had a better example
to look
Um, that's what basically all of the friends who have moral compasses
tell themselves, right? Is I will be an example. I will set this
guy straight. Okay? You can't fix this guy. You can't fix this
guy. You can't fix this guy. You can't fix this guy. That's what
everybody convinces every single person who pulls for this guy
and like defends this guy. All right? They all think they can
fix him. You cannot fix him. Nobody has been able to fix him.
You're not the one. Stop telling yourself you're the one. Stop
pretending you're the one, dude. This is exactly This is what
Connor thinks, by the way. Conor's like, "As long as I show him
how to be a good person, a good friend, he will change. she will
come over to me. It's like, yeah, you could probably criticize
him in the meantime. I'm just saying >> he would not have
done this because he would have had a better example
to look at. Okay, that hubris. Yes.
But I I don't know. I want to help people be a better person
than they are. Here's the thing, and it's going to sound weird.
>> Oh, I'm replaying. I'm replaying. Whoops. I'm replaying.
Yeah. Sorry. I thought that was uh I thought that was crazy just
to be like listen if if only if only he was friends with me guys.
That would be that would be amazing.
Yeah. He he wouldn't have done any of this guys. If if I'd been
his friend he wouldn't have done any of this. Delusional delusional.
Okay. Oh, there's a Vosch clip as well. I I heard this was Vosch
defending Destiny, but I have no >> I have no idea why
he would do that. I don't think he would do that beyond like
he would probably give a reciprocal defense. Okay, if Destiny
got caught with some lolly stuff, I'm sure he would give the
reciprocal defense for Destiny.
But in terms of this, I don't think Bosch going to go near that.
Okay,
I don't think so. If I got money from an inheritance and I'm
21 years old, how should I allocate it to get high returns? I
think you mostly just I I don't know why you wouldn't just throw
it in like some indexed fund like the S&P 500. Basically,
S&P look at the S&P 500 over time.
It's basically always a good decision.
There might be some higher return things, but
>> true. You actually mostly donate that to me in the form
of 5 to 10 subs every stream for a couple years.
Slime 712. I think that's the best way to handle it. Thank you.
Thank you. >> The Destiny drama. I know we don't care,
but like come on. >> Very low volume. I have it on full
volume. I'll restart it with way I have it on like a trillion
volume. >> The Destiny drama is so bad. I know we >> cannot
go louder than this. >> Look, it's not that we It's not
that we don't care necessarily because the tiny glimpses of it
that I see on the TL are
>> entertaining isn't even the right word. I don't know.
They're provocative. Um it's more like Jesus Christ. You know,
there's there's rubbernecking a car crash and then there's like
the the cars exploding and there's shards getting everywhere.
Like Jesus, what a mess.
Streamer slot. I'm I'm I'm sure Hassan has been covering it in
great detail.
>> I I've heard that >> this is, by the way, this
is somebody who when they were like, "You know what? I'm done
covering drama." They were actually, I think, mostly serious
on that, right? I feel like Vosch was like, "You know what? I'm
not doing drama stuff anymore. I'm just going to go politics
only." And I think he's been like, "Politics only andor his fashion
the whole time." He actually did opt out. He actually exited
the uh the loop. Okay. that uh Destiny is now an ardent defender
of Palestinian rights, possibly even a member of Hamas. So good
for him. >> That'll be on the bingo later, by the way.
Ironic support for Palestine. >> Eric Adams thinks it was
an embarrassment. The Destiny H3 drama. Yeah, I'm sure. Adam's
W. Adams W. Is the [__] against Dere. How the would
I know? The last person you seriously doesn't isn't Hassan talking
about all of this. >> This is uh this is like insane
self-control from Vos.
I don't know how he did like this is wild. You think of this
guy as somebody with no impulse control based on like the uh
I guess like the uh hentai consumption habits and stuff, but
this is insane self-control to just like he didn't have this
before. Where did this come from? This discipline to not just
sh from the hip. Remember remember didn't say Simon says. Do
we not remember that? Where did this self-control come from?
I haven't been watching this guy. This is weird. >> Yes.
All right. Well, there you go. >> Who called Vos? I don't
even know. I just I saw some people saying it was Vosch like
defending Destiny here. It sounds like he's just saying, "I don't
know. I don't care to look. Go watch Hassan. I bet Hassan's covering
it. I don't want to look. I don't care. >> I'd rather watch
you talk about it. Sorry. You have no choice but to actually
uh it for me. Listen, it's it's clothing or but >> Jesus
Christ.
>> Clothing or bust. >> Well, I'm glad a decade plus
of relentless contrarianism hasn't robbed him of his ability
to be um to be funny. >> Is he pulling a clip? >> This
is the only way I touch kids." That's good. I wonder who photoshopped
that. As a leftist, I can't condone the um
uncredited appropriation. >> That's uh that's the guy who
we watched with the drone. The drone comes in and like he throws
the stick at the drone and he gets taken out. Sinoir. Sinoir,
>> Sinir without compensation. >> Or is it Senoir?
The hairline makes me think Sinir. It might be the other guy
though. The other guy who's leading before the war started. >> Broader
sentiment. >> Actually, not totally sure. >> Matters
is that they're having fun. Also, check replies, "No, that's
okay,
>> dude. That's crazy self-control from Bosch." Okay, that's
wild stuff. Did not expect that at all. All right, I will leave
the subreddit for one more day and then I'll go through a bunch
of the subreddit stuff. Okay, we'll go through it.
But what we're going to do first is we have to we have to go
through with a
>> the Ethan Klein hit piece from start to finish. Okay,
we got to watch this. We got to take our notes. We got to figure
out what's good, what's bad about it, where he's going to be
attacked. Okay, we'll predict it before the uh the Destiny stuff.
Okay, we'll see. We'll see exactly what's going on. I think it
should be pretty easy
>> that we may have got wrong. So, Welcome back, guys,
to another video on demand. Today, I'm going to be addressing
once again the allegations leveled against Destiny. Since we
put out our last video, there's been a lot of chatter about the
things that we may have got wrong. So, I'd like to clarify what
I got wrong and also to clarify what I got right. So let's I
do want to start though by setting the expectations and just
kind of giving some context to who this guy Destiny is. I think
a lot of people haven't seen this and when you just I feel this
context is important.
So, I will say the thing I got told before this was essentially,
okay, it's essentially just he just replays the Ryan Beard piece,
which if he can follow the Ryan Beard narrative is good, but
the Ryan Beard narrative is
is not necessarily that Destiny is literally a Okay, Ryan Beard
gets that in there, but he makes his argument in a very specific
way. So, I'd be if I were Ethan, I'd be careful in the way you
lay out the argument. Make sure you follow the same path that
Ryan Beard does. All right? when understanding this story. So,
if you'll indulge me here, I'm going to pull up some clips from
this Ryan Beard uh video on him that was recently made. And I
think these clips are more relevant now than ever before. So,
let's take a look at them. Section here of harming women. I'm
going to show you guys a few. Around the end of 2011, Destiny
assaulted a woman on his live stream. I'm not using the word
allegedly here because we have video of him doing it and he has
openly admitted that it was assault. >> I would say that
in my streaming career in the past like totally >> I believe
that Destiny cope for this is I'd never had alcohol before in
my entire life and those people basically groomed me into assaulting
me a rose. It wasn't my fault at all. I'd never had alcohol before
and they groomed me. They they made me drink so much and then
I assaulted that woman I didn't even know what was going on.
Was the last cope I'd heard. publicly like I completely and totally
likely assaulted a girl on stream before for like 5 minutes or
whatever. I got super [__] drunk and was like grabbing
her [__] bre the entire time. Later, Destiny >> was
not quite as aggressive as that. That is not the latest >> co
attempted to downplay his actions here by tweeting, "I was drunk
off my ass literally for the first time in my life." And he said
that at the time he didn't understand how bad it was, but now
looking back years later, he understands that it was reprehensible
behavior. It's like that one guy Mango who got like totally cancelled
for did but way worse. Mango wasn't actually groping people.
And also there I like this this um there's this pretense that
like as long as you're radically honest about what you did it's
okay. It's like
it's called based. >> I would say radically honest and
apologetic and have sought forgiveness then like if if that's
the way it is and this Mia Rose clip could potentially this could
be the one thing although I don't think it is. I think Mia Rosa
said basically that she wasn't apologized to. No, that like they
they had talked and it was fine, but like she didn't get an apology.
Am I crazy on that one? But this could be the one. This could
be the one if I'm I I'll hold my I'll hold off a little bit.
This could be the one where it's like, okay, he actually did
seek forgiveness. He got forgiveness and that like this one maybe
isn't quite as tangible, right? I'd say for things that you've
like actually atoned for, I'm fine with leaving those in the
past. That but that's just me personally. Not everybody. Okay.
>> Did you just say you were groping a woman on stream
for 5 minutes? But anyway, that's not Honestly, that's far from
the worst thing I'm about to show you. Uh here's the next one
where he uh admits to sharing photos of a 15-year-old who sent
him bikini shots with his homies and how he couldn't resist barely
resist the urge of wanting to Destiny was 23. He shared in a
group chat with a couple of his friends the messages, "You want
to see the sickest [__] in the world? So many
>> Ah, come on. I I want to get all of these messages.
Okay, I need these in an >> Fan girls. I had one that was
15. She wanted to meet and hook up. Dude, she's 15. So many fan
girls. I had one that was 15. She >> Oh, hold on. I actually
have all of this right here. Let's go. Let's go. I actually have
one that was 15.
Wow.
Crazy.
She wanted to meet and hook up, says Destiny. Okay. >> Wanted
to meet and hook up. Dude, she's
>> Sorry, I I'm screenshotting these on the fly with you
guys.
We'll need them for >> But she sent me pictures that made
it so hard to say no. Then >> I just missed the
>> Did I
She sent me pictures that made it so hard to say no. Then Destiny
linked a picture of this girl in a bikini in the chat and said,
"Girl on the left, so hard to say no. Going to get arrested.
One of these MLGs, man." So, in these logs, when Destiny was
23, he said that it was really hard to turn down hooking up with
this 15-year-old because she looked so good in this picture of
her in a bikini. He then shared this LWD image of a child with
his friends and said that he's going to get arrested someday.
Imagine, okay, I'll be real, just as a little spoiler of what's
to come. I saw his defense of that and oh boy, is his defense
of that ever just a total lie. Like a complete and uttering
lie,
right? I believe his defense later on will be something along
the lines of I was just warning those guys that like there's
jailbait at these MLG events and to be careful. That's not what
you were doing. Receiving a >> Mia Rose tweet tweeted today
that he said sorry. Yeah. So like I said, I hadn't seen that
but um
but like that is one of the ones that I could leave in the past
like pretty much right where like he he apologizes, he gets forgiveness,
he he is honest about what he did and then he moves forward.
I can I can let that one go. Right. That's long enough ago that
is that I can just say, "Yeah, I can let that go." >> Bikini
pick from a 15-year-old in your DMs, a fan of yours, and being
like, "She's so hot. I need to share this with the boys." >> Chat,
I was talking with a bunch of other esports guys, and we were
basically talking about how crazy the jailbait is in the gaming
communities. It's ridiculous. I think I said something along
the lines of like, "There are 15-year-old chicks that are like
hot as [__] that will like try to send you pictures
to like [__] you at events and shit." And it's like,
you have to be really careful when you navigate that. >> So,
what does he >> That's what he says here. That's not what
the DMs say at all. This is him rewriting the DMs right here.
Right. He's not saying you got to be real careful when you navigate
that. Being real careful when you navigate that is not linking
the picture and going, "Oh, it's so hard to say no." Oh, it's
so hard to
It's so so hard to say no, guys. >> See, admitting that
you're off to 15year-olds and what is that in >> I never
admit to I think I just said like this I think the log is something
like this 15-year-old chick was trying to send me was sending
me pictures of herself and she was hot as [__] It's
like really hard to like turn down some of these people. I think
>> Wait, how old was she? >> Um, she said she was
15. So, you did get pictures from a 15-year-old. >> Not
nudes, though. Sorry, I should specify. I think a couple pics
of her like at the beach or some [__] But, um, >> dude,
Mr. Medicare won this conversation so hard. It's actually really
funny.
>> So, you're getting swimmer pick for >> Yeah. Hell
yeah, dude. This [__] >> That's crazy. That's
cra I'm sorry, >> Yeah, dude. This man needs to know that.
Okay, but again, >> that's not it. That's not all, folks.
Here's another one. When he was 26. A couple years later in 2015
when Destiny was 26, he shared in his chat, "I would the out
of that 15-year-old. What the
Oh, there's another log. There's no way that chick is 15. They
uh What did the Sweetie Bell person say? >> There's no
way that chick is 15." So now we've seen two separate occasions,
>> guys. This is not normal. You just don't type that kind
of stuff unless you're like Jared Fogle in a chat with his homies,
you know? Like he's speaking openly with the dogs who are like,
"Yeah, I know exactly what you mean." You would never say this
is not normal. And like he keeps getting older and older, but
the girls stay the same age. But again, that's not all, folks.
But the colloquial definition of pedophile is someone who is
attracted to children. And Destiny is at least somewhat attracted
to children. >> There are some 15 16-year-old chicks that
like look pretty like I can't I can't help that. Like some people
mature >> Destiny defended another streamer who got exposed
for having with a 14-year-old by saying, "Even if he did bang
a 14-year-old, no, that's not what pedophile means. Go look it
up." Seriously, if you don't understand the difference between
being attracted to someone that happens to be young and being
attracted to someone because they are young, you have absolutely
no business whatsoever commenting on the issue. Period. It makes
you look unedited. I really like it is so outrageous, sir, that
you would call someone sleeping with a 14-year-old.
How dare you, sir?
Even if you want to play this game where it's like actually >> Oh,
we should look up the truth of this cuz I'm pretty confident
that in this case, this is the Stfano case, right? I'm pretty
sure that in this case, Stefano did [__] that 14-year-old.
And the the real answer there is uh Shrug, it's France, okay?
He lives in France. He's a he's not a part of what you would
call the Lauren Southern would not consider him French. Okay,
Lauren Southern would not consider Stfano French. And of course,
a man of Stfano's background, you know, sleeping with a 14-year-old
French. That's like par. Is that not
par for the core? Actually, I want to um 16 and 17 year olds.
Um there's 14 is pushing it. 14? What are we talking about? This
man was like, "Yeah, you can 14-year-old." That's That's not
the same thing,
guys. Are we all hearing the same thing? It's 14. This dude has
made it like his personal crusade to normalize children. >> Okay,
whoever hit the soundboard there was actually on point. Okay,
that's funny as it's 14 pages.
Like how many times are you going to go on the record protecting
it? He goes 17 is cool, 15 is cool, 14 is not guys. Is 13? Is
12.
Where does it stop? I'd like to know his opinion on that. You
know, a lot of people kids start hitting puberty at 12. Some
girls start hitting puberty earlier than that. Is 10. Some girls
hit puberty by 10. Is that not pedophilia? Steven Benelli.
By the way, the second is just junior. Okay. You don't have you
don't get to play the the royal guard game with just being the
second. In fact, that's just Junior, which ironically is what
you call other girls. Come on over. >> Oh, Jesus,
dude. Ethan's not good at this, man. Ethan,
that's uh
that's a rough one right there. >> Here, Junior, come sit
in daddy's lap. >> Oh, yeah. But guess what, guys?
There's >> Is when him and his friends, the bro squad,
watched an 8-year-old boy, shake his for them on a live stream.
I shouldn't tell this because I'm going to get [__]
aggressive um for child protective services. >> By the
way, how many times has he said >> Not true. >> Once
enough, he said this like three times. He's like, I shouldn't
tell you guys this cuz I'm going to get arrested for child.
>> Three. How many times are we going to tell that joke?
>> I used to be part of this horrible thing called the
bro squad. Okay. Me, if you remember that cheeks and a couple
other people that have never been on my stream before, um we're
part of the bro squad. What we would do is we would go around
Justin TV streams trolling the [__] of these people
and we went around from channel to channel like around like it
was horrible. We went to this channel with this this kid was
like 8 years old and he was broing out with everybody in this
chat recently. This kid decides to take his pants off and wiggle
his eight-year-old on stream.
>> I can't even believe it. Oh my [__] god.
It was like I didn't even know like we were on Skype. We were
like, "Holy shit." Like we had to do like a double
What does trolling even mean here? Uh typing people's chats and
with them. The The thing is is uh the thing is is like with this
I don't think this is like indicative of like I think this is
indicative of like antisocial
some antisocial
thing going on, right? Where you don't understand like you're
doing really [__] up. And the weird thing here is
it sounds like it sounds to me like when he talks about this
like he just talks about it as like a one-off. Even here he knows
to frame it as a one-off, but it's clearly not a one-off, right?
They clearly had done this multiple times. They had nicknames
for the people. Like this wasn't just like a oneoff thing.
They knew this like 8-year-old kid is a streamer. It seems pretty
obvious, right? cuz we didn't even [__] know like
what the [__] was that? Like we were looking at like
an 8-year-old dick like on the [__] screen and his
[__] brother and his brother, we called him Captain
Push-ups, would like come in the room and this guy was like [__]
14 years old. He had his shirt off and he was like this like
watching the stream the entire time and [__] Oh my
god. What's interesting is he makes it seem like this kid just
happened to take his dick out. But they clearly spent a lot of
time there cuz they like had a nickname for the brother who was
there watching the whole time. Like this was a this was an intimate
setting in which there was a lot of time. Oh, Ethan actually
Ethan actually on point with the analysis for once. Let's go.
>> Here's another one, guys, in case you know you haven't
seen enough. This one comes to you courtesy of the Pope, uh,
Nicholas Dioro,
uh, or whatever it is they do. >> God bless. >> God
bless. >> Oh, I recognize the background there. This is
going to be 19-year-old might as well be 15 to me. Little little
did we realize that meant nothing. That was actually Destiny's
trying to say something, but it's actually a meaningless statement.
19-year-old might as well be 15 to me. Those are the Those are
the same thing to him, but it doesn't mean what you think it
means. >> Nicholas Bless >> years old. That's an
adult. That's an adult dog. No,
>> Oh, wait. Hold on. 19 years old. That's an adult. Never
mind. He actually makes it very clear what he means here. Uh-oh.
>> I'm 29. A 19year-old might as well be a 15year-old to
me. It's >> okay. That's That's the wor That's the worst.
Yeah, that's the worst clip. That's No, that's the worst clip.
>> Okay, I'm 29. A 19year-old might as well be a 15year-old
to me. It's all the same, dude. Don't give me this. >> The
defense to this will be, by the way, if Ethan isn't ready for
this. The defense will be No, I mean like in a relationship or
dating. In a relationship or dating. That's what I mean. Um I
guess we just have to skip what 2 years after this and he starts
dating at 19 and then marries Molina. But so it's it's like in
any case, right? But he's going to argue that like and like you
would totally have sex with a 19-year-old. It's just like a
>> that's such an interesting. >> This is exactly
what we're saying. He goes, "It's all the same, bro. 15, 13,
14, 15. It's all the same, bro. I'm 29." It also on the other
hand, it also is um a self-report because it it suggests he knows
exactly what he's doing. >> Of some legal age of consent,
whatever. >> Just because of some legal age of
>> huh? That's the age of consent. We I think we all agree
that's a good thing. Everyone but Destiny thinks that's good.
We should have a minimum age so that adults can't have with children.
Um, that is that is just an imagined line in the sand that >> Oh,
wait. Does Ethan think Desi is arguing the opposite side of this?
Oh, god. Please don't. I
>> think that's good. >> We should have a minimum
age so that adults can't have with children. >> Um, that
is that is just a >> bro like this is literally the VOD.
This is literally the VOD. Like this isn't done live. How do
you this up that badly? This is like one of those things
uh I've like made these same decisions before. Sorry, I've made
decisions based on this, but like the thing that Destiny thrives
on is having like ops that give him like free attack surfaces,
right? Like all he f he fuels his audience on like giving people
something to attack. And so what gets him through situations
even where he's in the wrong is giving his audience a surface
to attack that's not him, right? as long as he can present that
surface. So you the the key thing to do with Destiny when you're
criticizing him is to not give that surface to attack back to
not [__] up like major things because that is that
is where he'll he'll do this reverse attack vector and he usually
has a sicopantic enough audience that they can make that seem
really good even when he's like more in the wrong. So this would
be one example where I'm assuming he's going to go super hard
on this and just point out that Ethan clearly missed the point,
clearly this up doesn't care to actually get this correct, right?
Ethan is a major was carried by his producers. Well, his producers
that that's what I would say top Bronson, but they didn't even
release this like exactly one hour or a couple hours after the
podcast. They took a while to release this and it it's just not
well done at all, which is unfortunate, right? I'm already seeing
like major holes and we're 10 minutes in. Realistically, what
you do when you have Destiny's attention, the real trick here
for Ethan is to just give like five questions, do a threeminute
video, give five questions.
Uh, do you actually still doubt that despite Willie Mack and
Tom Fery coming together shaking hands and agreeing that Rose
is 17? Are you still doubting that Rose is 17 when you guys were
exchanging? How much of that material did you retain? Do you
acknowledge that Solo told you in November of 2024 that she was
a minor? Right. You just give these questions and that's all
you give him. Give him the things that you know he won't answer
that he'll opt out of. Right. By the way, he can opt out of any
question about the sorry he he doesn't he can answer any question
about the the is not valid evidence that can be presented in
any civil case. He cannot use his civil case as a distraction
from the if you're asking him about child porn. He cannot say,
"Well, I have a civil case, so I can't answer that." That that
can't be done. Sorry. That can't be done in good faith. That
can't be done legitimately.
If he's being asked about child, he can answer those questions.
Not valid evidence for anything else going on.
What's up, Uncord? How's it going, guys? All right, let's continue.
Cuz I'm I'm just saying like I think you give him only the things
that he doesn't want to see. If you give him a whole bunch of
stuff that he's like contended with before or you stuff up, you
just give him a lot of content to work with and you rally his
fans. Now, does that mean very much? No. Like we can go and dispassionately
analyze this and explain what all of it means,
but I'm just telling you that it it sucks when a big creator
digs into this stuff and then totally screws the pooch. You know,
it it just sucks when they totally screw the pooch. And I can
already see that Ethan's screwing the pooch a little bit. Okay.
Agent line in the sand that I will not conform to. Okay. He's
he's constantly blurring the line and trying to normalize the
act of adults sleeping. >> Destiny implies that he has
reported some of this. Well, we'll get into it to the police
a while ago. He didn't outright say it, but heavily implied that
you don't know what I've reported to the police. All I would
say there is Destiny, I want you to outright say you've reported
this to the police. I want you to outright say that when the
FBI came to your house, apparently that you told them about this,
right? You knew you knew that you might have seen at that point.
You should say that you outright reported it. Don't say, "I don't
you don't know what I've reported." Yeah, nobody knows what you've
reported. Are you saying you've reported it? Right. That's why
you don't give him like a bunch of stuff to work around. You
could just ask these questions and and make it so his silence
is deafening because that will be when we go to watch his response.
What we'll be watching for is what he avoids responding to, right?
The stuff he avoids responding to, those will be the attacks
that are hitting, right? He's going to fill up a bunch of time
with where Ethan screws up and he'll totally avoid all of the
things Ethan asks that are actually relevant >> with minors,
right? Continually. This is the theme that we keep seeing. He's
like, "This is okay. This isn't that bad. This 15-year-old's
hot. I want to this 15-year-old, but I won't, etc., etc. This
is a pattern. Long, long
>> I have about as much in common with like an 18-year-old,
19-year-old freshman in school as I would a [__]
sophomore in high school. Any type of inclination >> he's
like freshman in college, sophomore in high school. It's all
good, baby. Send me those bikini pics in the DMs. >> Those
people is really weird. Okay, now I know if you're 20 years old,
it might bother you to hear that. Like, no, I'm 19. I'm a real
adult. Okay. And then there's one more clip I want to show you
guys of when we were talking about Vosch and the Loi horse controversy
and he accidentally opened a folder and he had lolly and horse
on his computer and >> I I have a feeling, okay, if I had
to if I had to guess here,
I have a feeling that Ethan finds this clip um compelling and
probably everybody around him was saying like, "Ethan, this isn't
really that big a deal. Ethan, you shouldn't use this clip. It's
not really a good It's not really a good one. Ethan, you we should
skip this one." And Ethan's like, "No, I remember this. I remember
when he defended Loi." >> He was clowning on him. Except
one person. There was one person that came to his defense. Who
was it? Destin. >> Why? Well, this this take was so bizarre.
I remember at the time being absolutely struck by it. And I pulled
this straight from my memory because it was just so just so shocking
to me. But here here's his take on on a lollycon, which is the
uh hentai drawings involving children. >> you see the loll
discussion on Reddit? You know, if Vaj was a better person and
such a piece of I'd be in the trenches cuz you know what? Who
the [__] Who cares about drawn? Imagine your life
is so boring that you give a [__] about animated
cartoon girls. >> Imagine your life so boring that you
care about children. Imagine being so bored in your life that
you actually care if grown-ups want to minor.
Bro, what? I don't know. I I don't know. That's That's rough
when it's just your wife. Only your wife laughing in the background.
Okay. You got like five people in that studio who could laugh
into their mics and it's just your wife gives like the courtesy
>> if it's that minor of a detail. >> Like how old
is the girl? I don't know. How old is the drawing? It's a goddamn
picture. Who the [__] cares? Grow the [__]
up. Okay. People on either side are like calling the FBI. >> Uh
the weirdest thing is Destiny didn't even come to Vos's defense.
You're just wrong. You're just wrong, Slime. He is explicitly
defending Vos here. This is him explicitly defending Vos. He
goes, "If Vos if Vos would have been nicer to me, I'd defend
him." And then he explicitly defends. Not even like close to
an just explicitly defending the exact thing with Vaj. Right.
>> Care if grown-ups want to [__] >> We
just listen to it again. >> Bro, what? I don't know. I
I don't know if it's that minor of a >> So So that's the
funny thing is a bunch of people have been saying like, "Oh,
no. I thought Destiny said he wasn't going to defend Bosch."
Well, he does say that. Okay, he does say it and then he goes
on to explicitly defend Bosch the whole the the whole rest of
the >> Like how old is the girl? I don't know. How is the
[__] drawing? It's a goddamn picture. Who the cares?
Grow the up. Okay, people in either side are like calling the
FBI on Vouch. He's looking at cartoons that I don't like. I think
that like, bro, >> that's not the criticism. It's not that
they don't like it. Uh, it might have a fine plot. The plot might
be a banger. I don't know. The problem, of course, is that it's
depicting children being [__] by adults. That's just,
you know, that's a detail that's important to uh to emphasize.
>> Care. Okay. Call me when this guy's his way through
some [__] preschoolers. Okay. Until then, get out
of here. Who cares? And then he sets this bar. He goes, "I only
care until you're preschoolers," which is three-year-olds, bro.
Three year olds. Kindergarten good to go, baby. First Oh, this
is another thing that dude, this is another thing that's going
to be actually annoying.
Like, there are with so many tangible things going on, okay?
The the way to attack the jokes is not to soy about the jokes,
okay? Or take them literally. That's not that's not the way to
attack it, okay? The way to attack the jokes is to say, "Listen,
I thought those were all jokes. They seem like jokes to me, but
given that Destiny, okay, you you hear that joke, you go, listen,
that joke sounds innocuous, right?" But the way I felt comfortable
with Destiny joking about kids was he always made it clear where
the lines were, right? He knew where the lines were. He made
very strong boundaries across those lines. Here's a clip that
I've just seen >> I really wouldn't rule out that 17-y
old girl. Now, now this is a clip I've just seen recently,
and this this basically totally [__] him. Okay, this
totally [__] him from the um from like of any defense
he's going to mount on this. Honestly, I really wouldn't rule
out that 17-year-old girls could have lied about their age or
generally put it off to an older guy. Okay, but like look at
the girl's Instagram. Does she have pictures of her graduating
high school or does she have pictures of her like on the junior
so like softball team or some [__] It should be pretty
easy looking at somebody's Instagram to find out. And if you're
a celebrity, you should probably be playing it like pretty safe.
anyway, right? Like, so you should probably be playing it pretty
safe anyway. Isn't that shocking that he would say, "Listen,
guys, as a celebrity, you probably just don't play close to the
line." This is like, okay, Destiny's playing wreck dodgeball
right now. Okay, wreck dodgeball. except the center line is having
interactions with a minor and he keeps tiptoeing across this
center line right on the edge over and over and then he steps
over the line and the ref calls him out and he goes to the ref
and he goes, "Dude, I've never walked over that line before.
Are you really going to pretend I meant to walk over that line?"
It's like, "We watch you playing on the line. We watched you
do it. What? Who are you trying to fool right now?" And you've
literally talked about how anybody who plays on that line is
a Especially when they're a celebrity, especially when they have
something to lose. You've literally explained to us why you need
to be out of the game. Now, you've you all I have to do is play
clips of you explaining it like on the junior so like softball
team or some [__] It should be pretty easy looking
at somebody's Instagram to find out. And if you're a celebrity,
you should probably be playing it like pretty safe anyway, right?
Like I'm at a stage in my life where I I try to air on the side
of caution. Like there have been girls that have messaged me
that have said like they're 19 or 20 or whatever and then I looked
at their Instagram. I was like I'm not sure. I think I'm going
to stop talking to you cuz I'm not even going to like Jesus Christ.
Like if
uh funny memes in the background. I'm not totally sure of the
date here. Oh wait, I can be sure of the date. It is June 23rd,
2020. So this would be around the time he was dating Molina,
right? This would be after he'd been dating Molina. So that would
have been an 18, 19year-old who started DMing him, just to be
clear. Okay. If you have pictures of a girl getting on a school
bus, okay? And the date of this picture is like 2017, maybe you
should back off a little bit, okay? Maybe we should apply a little
bit of common sense. All right? And maybe like calm the down.
Um I don't know. Like you're just like, why would you even ride
that line? Why would you be so Why would you Jesus Christ? Okay.
It's very funny to me
that he actually just identified something for us there that
would have been very effective in determining whether or not
Rose was the age she said she was. Hey, I don't need your ID,
but could you give me your Instagram? Could you give me your
Instagram, Facebook, some profile where I can see pictures of
you and confirm that, you know, you've gone through that coming
of age ceremony that is high school graduation?
That would be cool if I could confirm that, right? But he didn't
he didn't do that, did he? Did he? So suffice to say, this clip
is no, you don't give somebody charity because they a 17-year-old.
When you're a celebrity, you have to do more due diligence. You
have to play it way further away from that line cuz crossing
that line is cataclysmic for you. And so you hear you hear things
like this where he clearly annunciates
his exact understanding of why you don't get close to that line.
And then you see four years, sorry, two years later where he
steps on that line and accidentally goes over it intentionally
and you go, "Oh, um, he knows exactly why he shouldn't do that.
He knows exactly what he should be looking for to make sure it
doesn't happen and he didn't do those things."
Now, now that that's happened now all your jokes seem a little
more suspect to me. Right? Again, we tied this into the concept
with Mr. Girl where Destiny didn't want to call him a right and
then something's changed, right? He's decided he didn't trust
Mr. girl as much. Thought Mr. Girl was a liar. So now his priors
have updated. Now the jokes from before don't seem quite as funny.
And that's how you attack Destiny's jokes. You don't just go
and look at them and go, "Oh my god, preschool. That's like 3
years old. That's like, oh my god, he's talking about three-year-olds.
He needs Vos to three-year-olds for us to get mad at him." No,
that's not that's not at all what's going on here. Okay.
All right. So that's how you go after it. You don't you don't
do the uh the total like soy route like Ethan's doing here. >> First,
second, third, fifth grade, basically an adult. And honestly,
this is just a few of many many many clips of him.
Why would there a worker give out their personal social medias
to random people though? I don't know if they would. But if you
were very concerned about that worker being under the age of
18, there's a couple things you could do to try to figure out
if they're over the age of 18. You could ask them for a profile,
an age verified site. You could ask them for some social media
that could back it up. You could ask them for their ID that could
back it up. If you see none of these things, right? If you see
none of these things,
then as Destiny said, you got to play it safe, right? You got
to play it safe there. Yeah, you got to play it safe. That's
what you got to do. >> Children and just being a total
deviant, right? So, with that important back story, now let's
go to the parts that I got wrong that I'm going to issue a heartfelt
apology for. And this goes out a sincere apology. I guarantee
you, by the way, I've not watched through I don't know if I've
watched through this part yet. There's no way Ethan's gonna Ethan's
apologies whenever he's like with one of his ops, whenever he's
like, "Oh, I have to issue an an apology to you." The apology
is always a double down, right? He's going to go, "Oh, I apologize
for getting this wrong, but I was right." In essence, every single
time, he'll never actually get something wrong and go, I need
to apologize for to you to Destiny for absolutely getting this
wrong. Now, here's what happened. This conversation here where
he says, "Uh, Tehe, send me the feed pics." This is from a different
girl. It's from Instagram. He never spoke to Rose on Instagram,
which he points out correctly, as far as we know. So, this was
with another girl he claims was 26. Okay, fine. I'll take your
word for it. And then this one also he claims was with the same
girl. And this is the one that says, "She said, "My parents are
like super super strict. Don't do this. Don't do that. Don't
go there. Don't talk to him." And he said, "Well, it would be
so hot to drive you home from a date and make you suck me off
in the car. I'd love to send you inside your parents after making
you swallow. >> Don't do the Don't do the voice. >> Full
load from me." So, apologies. Um,
you know, that was not to Rose. This was to some other lucky
lady. >> Gross, dude. >> But this one, however, is
from Rose. >> That's very gross. >> And it is pretty
weird. Uh, this is from 22. She says, "I'm probably getting my
braces off in a couple weeks." What What image is that Andre
in your mind? Right. And he says, "A exciting.
Are you looking forward to it? He's talking to her like she's
a child." But okay, there's nothing explicit here, right? So,
fair enough. So, I I am making a sincere apology for getting
this wrong. Now, while two of the screenshots were not attributed,
>> is he not going to go is he not going to go through
more of the logs? Is he not going to talk about like how many
times? Where's the picture? Somebody get me the meme of all the
times Destiny was like, "Hey, I I'm flying like near you. I could
I could be over there in a second. Hey, I'm going to come I'm
going to come kidnap you. Hey, just you ever want to fly to Miami,
let me know. I got points. Hey, you ever want to fly to Miami?
You ever want to fly to Miami? You ever Hey, you want to fly
to Miami? You want to fly to Miami? Can we get Do we get that?
Cuz I don't know how you don't show that with this person who's
like ostensibly 18 at the time. >> My mistake. I >> uh
sorry. Ostensibly who he might have the idea is like 18 at the
time.
Maybe maybe still don't know why. And and I feel like Destiny
and his friends like Abba who who are making videos defending
him are avoiding this fact that he told Willie Mack three times
that he had child on his on his hard drive. Let me refresh your
memory >> while sending me a screenshot of the alleged
CP. So I asked to confirm if he just did that. If you were sending
me this, I'm guessing you still have that video. Destiny replies,
"Depends on why you're asking, but yes, I created copies of all."
>> So here, right above, he's acknowledging. He says, "Yeah,
that's absolutely to think about him doing all this if she was
17." He thinks it's funny. So he knows she's might have been
17. He's saying it right here. And then Willie Mack being extra
careful to make sure that he's not misquing Destiny says, "Just
to confirm, you're saying you still have this video of a
Uh, I watched the ABBA video.
I
It's whatever. I It didn't seem very good. Didn't seem very well
done. He kind of ends up He's like half good, half not great.
I don't know. It is what it is. Ethan Ethan gets things wrong
all the time and that's that makes it really difficult to focus
on like uh Destiny's wrongdoing and AB was friends with him.
I have no idea what's what's going on there now, right?
Um so Ethan Ethan just really is muddying this whole thing up
which is okay. Like I'm I'm kind of okay with Ethan muddying
it up just from the point of view that like it's driving more
eyes to all of this stuff and I do think people will eventually
get on to some of the more relevant information. I think there
will be videos coming out, right? I I can't imagine that there
aren't a lot of video essaists looking at this Destiny situation
going, "Oh, this is like perfect." Right?
This is priming people so they have interest in this topic, they
will go back. They will watch, you know, if there's a like if
there's an internet anarchist video on this or something, right?
People will watch it now. >> Engaged in activity on your
hard drive. And he says, >> "Dude, Abba just wants to posture
that he's not part of the zoo." He broke out the artful tech.
ABBA is a part of the zoo. Abba is always has always been a part
of the zoo. The the idea that he wants to say he's outside of
the zoo while being in one of the exhibits. Okay, this is like
a meta zoo. He is absolutely there. Okay, this is the lion looking
over at the penguins and saying, "Huh, look at those silly penguins
over there in their stupid enclosure. Sure glad I'm not captured
like them. Sure glad I'm not I'm not an exhibit and a figure
of fun like they are." And I will tell you directly, yes. He
says yes. When somebody asks you, "Do you have child on your
computer?" you always say,
That's a hard and fast rule. And hopefully it's true, right?
And again, equally creepy. Fingers crossed. So, you have that
video. And Destiny responds, "Uh, depends on why you're asking
because once again, he's implying that under the right circumstance,
he would send this video to Willie M. That's what that means.
I don't see any other way to see that." What does that >> I
have no idea why Ethan says this. I don't know what that means.
I Ethan I think Destiny's clearly joking there. If I had to guess
he's clearly joking that um like he would send >> you're
not report
that. What does that mean? Uh it depends on why >> get
back to the logs but I think that's the sweaty is like you're
not reporting me or something are you? Willie Mack is looking
to report you and you correctly sensed that that was the vibe
and you correctly
were like well but yes or sorry you incorrectly were like but
yes I do have copies of all of that. >> Are you trying
to tell the police or are you trying to get off? You're trying
to get off. send it to you. If you're calling, if you're talking
about reporting me to the police, then I'm not going to send
it to you. But actually, I will anyway cuz I'm a I'm apparently
the dumbest person alive. So, Destiny and ABBA and all these
people defending him are avoiding this critical moment in which
when pressed three different times, he has confirmed, yes, I
have child on my computer.
Okay. So, what I would expect here, okay, if Destiny was holding
on to this would be for him to say, "No, I don't have access
to the child right now or something along these lines." Something
that leaves out the clear fact that he is holding a hard drive
in his possession somewhere in his possession that would have
all of this child on it. Right? I would that's what I'm expecting
from Destiny is to say, "Well, I don't have access to it now.
Like, it's not on my computer I'm using."
Right? I think that's the the shift he's going to do to say like,
well, I've well, I had to preserve it and like I don't have access
to it now,
right? But I don't believe that if he was honest with anybody
about what's on it, I do not believe he would hand that hard
drive over to somebody um and that person would just keep it,
right? Whether that's his lawyer or anybody but the police.
But to continue on our messages and everything when that court
case started, just to be clear, he's admitting to having alleged
CP downloaded on his computer. He literally has the video open
as I'm talking to him. I go, "Bro, there's been >> Yeah.
Uh, so with that Willy Mack allegation, I'm guessing the frame
he sent is from a different group chat or
>> at least since my last video that she was underage and
you still have potential CP of her." >> So, and again,
that's an important detail Willie saying is that people knew
that there was a chance people already, we all done known that
she might have been underage this whole time and you still kept
it. >> I have an obligation to preserve relevant evidence,
etc. So, I created backups of all of the important relevant conversations.
So, this is another one of his big defense points that I want
people to pay attention to. He's saying, "My lawyer told me to
keep this potential child
for evidence, which is completely not true." And by the way,
why wouldn't he lie about it? He's literally he's being confronted
for having child at this point. Why wouldn't he lie? The fact
that people are actually believing him on that is totally insane.
The lawyer will not tell you to keep potential child in your
hard drive. Period. Having the po having it is the crime. There
is no situation where private citizen can have videos of minors
in positions on legally. There's no such thing as holding it
for evidence. And by the way, if you were so
this is what potentially criminal said. I've not seen any lawyer
say otherwise. In fact, I think it goes so far as you it can't
be evidence. You cannot turn it over as evidence. So the idea
that you would keep it as evidence to turn it over is insane.
It cannot be turned over to in a civil case to a civil uh opponent
in a case as evidence. You cannot transmit it to them. That would
possibly be transmission like copying this over to a different
person. That might be a crime in and of itself.
>> You know, concerned about her safety. >> He's
like, I listen, I had to I had to save this child porn because
in my civil case, I was trying to rack up another charge of transmitting
child porn. That's why I was saving the child. Like that doesn't
work, bro. It doesn't work at all. Could have reported it to
the police 6 months ago when her boyfriend told you about it.
Right. Continuing on. >> Think I'm allowed to delete it.
Lol. I don't know if it counts as hiding/ >> That's funny
about that. I don't know if it counts as hiding, destroying evidence.
Well, why don't you ask your lawyer who he's apparently talked
to? So, he says, "I've talked to my lawyer. They told me to keep
potential child, but at the same time, I don't know if it counts
as hiding or destroying
you didn't discuss that with your lawyer because if you did that
would be the heart of the conversation you would be having.
So it sounds to me that you didn't talk to your lawyer which
is obvious to anyone with a brain because the lawyer would have
said we need to send this to the judge. We need to send this
to the police. We need to get this off your hard drive. We need
to notify everybody because you are doing a crime right now sir.
And by the way I'm sure your lawyer really appreciates you saying
that they told you to keep potential child. I think that that's
awesome and they're going to totally love being implicated in
this crime. And by the way,
hello.
>> What do we got here? Underscored with the five gifted.
Let's go. Thank you very much, Underscore, for the five. Appreciate
it, buddy. Thank you. Thank >> The tiny minute things that
you can break client confidentiality with as an attorney, child
having it is one of them. Now, when Destiny says his lawyer told
him to keep all the evidence relating to the case, the lawyer
absolutely and obviously told him that. That's spoilation. That's
standard stuff. But what I doubt I would put money on that that
he never told his lawyer that in that body of evidence was potentially
a child having or doing acts. It was apparently her having sex
with men. But child, right? Potentially. There's no lawyer in
the country and I've worked with a lot of them that would risk
their freedom, their reputation, their license by not handling
that correctly. >> I'm allowed to delete it. Lol. I don't
know if it counts as hiding/destroying evidence. And I reply
talk to a lawyer. That seems crazy to me. who keeps this sort
of stuff on their computer without 100% knowing if they're supposed
to or not. Isn't that something you want to confirm? I >> uh
Willy's on uh on Twitter recently like totally farming the uh
totally farming all of this stuff. By the way, I find it very
funny cuz now he's Dude, the we're in the we're in the stone
toss tugofwar right now. Okay, that's where we are. We're in
the stone toss tugof-war situation where like there's very strange
bed fellows happening. All right, very very strange bedfellows.
Suddenly we have like Tom Foolery on her side pulling for like
for like uh No, actually she was a minor and a bunch of DJers
on the other side, right?
I It's very Everything's gotten jumbled. I don't I don't even
know who's on what side anymore. >> We know you have CP
videos saved to your computer. You knew it was alleged that she
was underage. You still have them. >> Now Willie being
extraordinarily fair once again clarifies for the third time
and he says it explicitly just to confirm. You told me you have
child pee saved on your computer. You knew it was alleged she
was underage and you still have them. Don't you see how this
is [__] up? You cannot be more clear in the accusation.
Now, if you didn't do any of this, what would your response be
to this? It's like, bro, what the I don't have child. What are
you talking about? That's insane, right? What? That's crazy.
Let's see what he says. >> The last message he sent me
was, "What? I don't even know 100% of her age was legitimately
less than 18 when these >> That doesn't matter. The fact
that you're not 100% sure is the problem and you have it uncorbella.
Just everything you said, right? Lee deleted his tweet about
Desty skipping his DMs already after DG spam reacted. Oshar was
in those replies instantly. Wait, I don't even know what you're
talking about, Jacob, but we'll get to it eventually. I was going
to go back and address what Porter Bella was saying. Yes, Willie
did. When Willie totally lied based on getting messages from
Destiny, right? Shouldn't it be incumbent on Willie to come out
and apologize for spreading Destiny's lies again with no evidence
whatsoever? He took the advice of a of soon to be convicted of
child possession. Possibly, possibly, possibly. Seems that way.
Okay. Seems like things are leaning that direction. But he took
the advice of this person that he was being doxed by like Queen's
community, Jay's community, all these people. And he just ran
with that fully trusting that guy. And then two weeks later,
he runs a video saying like, "This guy actually told me he has
he's in possession of we all need to get him." And now instead
of going and saying, "Well, that thing I did before that was
totally based on his word." Well, like that was wrong and I apologize.
He's just pretended it didn't
How How does anyone let him get away with that? That's nuts.
He still came out and just blatantly slandered people because
he has like a grudge, a petty, spiteful grievance.
Pretty disgusting, but he's going to get away with it. Well,
for a little bit. For a little bit. For a little bit. >> So,
basically, he's not 100% sure if he has child on his computer.
He's just 99% sure. Got it. Two. I'm pretty sure I have an obligation
to preserve stuff related to my court case. I talked about it
with >> pretty sure. What does pretty sure mean? I like
to be when I'm dealing with possible child in the future or whatever.
I don't even know where this could happen. Okay. If I were to
deal with possible child,
the level of certainty I'd like to have is concrete, absolute,
100%.
No doubts left, no possible issues remaining, right? I don't
want to be dealing with possible child in some situation. Go,
I'm pretty sure. I'm like 8020 I'm good here. I'm like 8020.
We should be good here. Right. You never I don't understand how
you could be in that situation and not just be like 100%. and
it's gone to the the police. We've done something. Yeah, I know
the phrasing was bad, but but yes, you if you're ever put into
that situation, right, you don't want to be in a in a like muddied
situation at all. You want to be
>> That part's true. Generally speaking, >> with
my lawyer already, specifically with regards to the road, >> that's
a lie in my humble uh godlike opinion. No, that's it has to be.
Or sue me. God, sue me for defamation. He's lying. He never told
his attorney he might have child on his hard drive. That never
happened. And if I'm wrong, God, strike me down with lightning
bolts and make Destiny sue me and take me for all I'm worth.
This man never told his attorney that.
>> So, he went from I don't know if I could delete this
to my lawyer says it's totally fine to keep. I don't know the
law, but the idea that his lawyer would tell him to hold on to
CP for a civil case just doesn't seem likely to me. Law Tube
can figure that out. Three, if someone were to come up, >> he
says Law Tube can figure that out. And funnily enough, um, Legal
Mindset did put out a video on it that I watched, and his conclusion
was Destiny is basically if he says if this girl was a minor,
which pretty much is confirmed by now, according to Willie Mack,
he's something to turn over to the authorities. If hypothetically,
whenever a political creator is about to give a hypothetical,
you know, you're about to hear some weird. If hypothetically
her boyfriend or whatever was actually trafficking her, getting
her to other dudes on video for him, and if there was ever some
kind of investig, >> would you have with a child if it
would stop a nuclear bomb from exploding in New York? Would you?
What? >> Dude, Ethan Ethan is just showing us, okay, that
he's like one 120 120th as funny as Hassan. Okay. Kind of riffing
off of a Hassan joke. Really running into the ground. Totally
failing to make it. Okay. You >> not good. Not good. >> Exactly.
The clock is ticking. You this kid or the whole city blows up.
Come on. Oh, so you let everyone die. I see. You'd rather murder
millions of people than child. Destiny's like I would. It was
funnier when Hassan did it, too, because it was about with Hassan.
Okay, to be fair, that joke came from Well, Hassan chatter was
funnier and Hassan get did it better. Okay, Ethan had the same
script and he [__] do the right thing and [__]
the [__] out of that child to save New York City.
>> That's the craziest version of 24 ever. I also want
to clarify that the crew is catching a lot of for apparently
brainwashing me, uh, manipulating me to talk about this. And
this, I just want to clarify, is my passion project. This I brought
to them after I saw the Willie Mack video. And I've always been
passionate throughout my whole career about these influencers
who are taking advantage of their fans. >> Strike Ethan
down just for the hubris. But as one of my chosen people, he's
suffering enough. >> Okay. Thank you very much, God, for
the >> For gratification specifically, it keeps happening.
It's this insane pattern. It disgusts me and I would be a total
hypocrite to see this and not call it out. Now, here's what happened
because I got the screenshots wrong. Admittedly, that was my
mistake. They've hyperfocused in on being like, "Dude, those
screenshots weren't even with Rose. This whole thing is a farce."
No, I will tell you exactly what happened. Okay, so this girl
Rose, she was selling nudes on Twitter when Steven approached
her at the time. He did not know she was 17. That is correct.
He thought she told him that she was 19 at the time. And that's
what he thought. Has anyone asked Destiny why Rose was selling
nudes on >> Right. I've never even heard of that. Why wouldn't
she be selling nudes on Only Fans? >> Now, now it seems
like Ethan Ethan stumbled on to the strongest talking points,
which are my talking points.
my the things I harp on because they are by far the optically
best points to harp on. Okay, not to not toot actually completely
to toot my own horn, okay? 10-second narcissism break. Okay,
I'm the best. I'm the greatest. These are the greatest points.
Thank you very much, Ethan, for getting to them. All right. But
yes, why why did he not, you know, hey, could I get you to can
I get you to like go show me your profile on or only fans where
you've like posted videos so I can confirm that you're above
18? Is it because Only Fans makes you verify that you're at least
18 to sign up and Twitter doesn't, right? Selling nudes on Twitter
is already a red flag. It's extremely weird. Why aren't you doing
it on Only Fans? The marketplace for this where everybody is.
When these influencers are chatting up their young fans, there's
a almost it's almost a certainty that people are going to lie
to you about their age. And like if you actually want to engage
with them in this extremely risky, borderline
activity, you need to make goddamn sure they're of age. And honestly,
over the internet, I don't even know if that's possible, which
is why you just shouldn't do it, right? Like you can look at
someone and be like, "That person's very young, like maybe 22
at oldest." And you say, "You know what? I am not gonna engage
with this because I'm 33 years old and I don't want to receive
nudes from minors. But anyway, so far not to >> It's almost
like It's almost like honestly I really wouldn't rule out that
17-year-old girls could have lied. >> Let's hear Let's
hear that exact point from Destiny. I'm going to grab some water
real quick. I'll be right back. >> Honestly, I really wouldn't
rule out that 17-year-old girls could have lied about their age
or generally played it off to an older guy. Okay, but like look
at the girl's Instagram. Does she have pictures of her graduating
high school or does she have pictures of her like on the junior
so like softball team or some [__] It should be pretty
easy looking at somebody's Instagram to find out. And if you're
a celebrity, you should probably be playing it like pretty safe
anyway, right? Like I'm at a stage in my life where I I try to
air on the side of caution. Like there have been girls that have
messaged me that have said like they're 19 or 20 or whatever
and then I looked at their Instagram. I was like, I'm not sure.
I think I'm going to stop talking to you cuz I'm not even going
to like Jesus Christ. Like if you have pictures of a girl getting
on a school bus, okay, and the date of this picture is like 2017,
maybe you should back off a little bit, okay? Maybe we should
apply a little bit of common sense. All right? to maybe like
calm the down. Um I don't know. Like you're just like why would
you even ride that line? Why would you be so Why would you Jesus
Christ? Okay. Celebrating their sweet 16 in 2019. Maybe it's
time to like put the phone down. Honestly. Wow. Wow. Wow. What
a clip, guys. What a clip. What a
>> Peterson just tipped five. >> Hello, Jordan. >> Destiny
represents the Jungian archetype of Satan. He thrives off of
letting others know his deeds are evil and making them defend
him. Anyway, >> uh that sounds very accurate, Jordan. Thank
you very much. Okay, dude. That's that's a clip from 2020. He
was dating Molina at the time, by the way, who he found via I
believe Instagram DMs. I've heard when she was 18 was when they
started messaging. I don't know that for a fact. At minimum,
or sorry, at most she was 19. Okay. But uh but he lays it out
right there. I'm a celebrity so I I have to play it way care
way more careful. Okay. I have to be certain because I'm a celebrity,
so I'm way more >> Money, the waters, he hasn't done anything
wrong, right? Okay. Then this is when the mistakes begin. In
November of 2024,
her boyfriend reaches out to Steven and we have the DM because
her boyfriend posted it. So, here's her boyfriend sending him
a message. It says, "Anyway, she was underage while sending you
the vast majority of that stuff. and from what I've heard from
her, you are pretty negligent about confirming her age, even
asking for ID at one point on Twitter and then saying it was
okay, just a joke. And he responded by saying, "That's pretty
weird considering that she told me she was of age and was selling
not safe for work material to people, but okay." So, what we
have here is a confirmation from Steven in November of last year
that there was at least a possibility that this girl was a minor,
that he has images of a minor. What happened around this time
was that including her messages with Destiny. Now, people theorized
at the time that she might be a minor, but they didn't know for
sure, which is why these, you know, psychos online hyperfocused
in on this because they're like, I think,
>> dude, okay, hold on. Keep listening for a second. I
want to try to prove it so we can nail Destiny. So, it wasn't
even like the boyfriend told him. There was already this idea
that she might have been a minor, which was the whole reason
for this hub. So, he knew she was maybe a minor and he kept the
footage. So, from this moment,
>> oh my god. Yes, Ethan. Yes, Ethan's cooking. Okay, Ethan's
on the railroad tracks. All right, he's on the railroad tracks.
He's in He's locked in. These are all great points. I'm looking
forward to the Destiny react to this portion of the video. Okay,
cuz I don't know I don't know how he deals with any of this stuff
to tell you the truth. Okay, I don't know how he deals with it.
Now, I just got linked a video. All right. Or sorry, not a video,
a tweet of Tom Fery. All right. Tom Fery today
10 minutes ago. Okay. Brand new Tom tweet. All right. He says
he says this. Okay. I know people are convinced these DMs are
proof Destiny didn't get any ID from Rose, but Destiny says he
thinks she sent him an ID and piece of paper with writing on
it. These DMs leave a lot of room for other possibilities. Maybe
something like this. Okay,
so Tom is doing his hypothetical. Guys, there's a there's still
a hypothetical word world where both Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
can still win the 2016 Democratic primary and Destiny might not
have been as close to the line. He might not have been playing
with fire as much as we think. Okay, Tom might sorry, Destiny
might have confirmed her age and Bernie could still win. I swear
I know these. So, maybe it's something like this. Hey there,
big boy. Let's get jiggy with it. You're hot as but 18. What
the? Also, one day old account. Hm. I wanted to send you some
mcnasty photos. So, buckle up, bucko.
Why is Tom doing this? Tom just Yes, actually, Latigious Gamer,
thank you. Tom just wanted to get his thoughts in on how Destiny.
Okay, he just wanted to roleplay with Destiny, and he's
okay. Jesus Christ.
All right. Oh, well, I mean, I'm flattered if I if you wanted
to. Sure. Yeah. Preferably one near an ID so I know you're at
least 18.
But I understand if that's too much info you'd be comfortable
showing. Is a college ID okay? Yeah, that's fine. Sorry, I don't
have my license with me. I know you're worried about me being
a troll account since it's only one since it's only one day old.
How about I hold a piece of paper with your name written on it
and so you know I'm not just a stealing nudes from some OF girl
just writing something on a wait hold on that this would not
have been what she said precisely, but she would have said like
I can prove that I'm real, right? This this is way less likely
than just like, "Hey, I can prove I'm real." And Destiny says,
"Yeah, this is how you can prove you're real, right? Is this
actually what Rose said or is Tom just crazy?" Tom is making
this up. He's saying that there's a way Destiny, she could have
sent Destiny an ID. Now, if that college ID doesn't have her
birthday on it, it's a problem, right?
It's a problem. Tom won. He trolled you. Is Tom joking here?
Is this just a meme? Maybe it's just a meme. I feel like this
is his honest thinking on this fully. Okay.
I think that's I think that's straight up what he believes happened
here. I'm going to be real with you guys. Okay, let's go back
to this real quick. So,
even asking for ID at one point on Twitter, then saying it was
okay slash a joke. That's pretty weird considering what she told
me was she was of age. So, Destiny doesn't say no, I saw her
ID. No, I saw her college ID. He doesn't say that back, right?
It sounds like Solo knows what the DM said. Okay, that's what
it sounds like to me. Solo Solo seems to know what those DMs
said and Destiny's playing around it. And now that he's now that
Destiny's like reviewed these, I think now he's got a narrative
around them, right? Like, oh no, I did ask her for like an ID
something. I totally did. But he doesn't say here, no, I saw
her ID and it's fine. He doesn't say that here at all. Very interesting.
Okay, let's move forward back to where we were here, 45, >> that
this girl was a minor, that he has images of a minor. What happened
around this time was that, including her messages with Destiny.
Now, people theorized at the time that she might be a minor,
but they didn't know for sure, which is why these, you know,
psychos online hyperfocused in on this because they're like,
I think these are a minor, and I want to try to prove it so we
can nail destiny. So, it wasn't even like the boyfriend told
him. There was already this idea that she might have been a minor,
which was the whole reason for this hub. So, he knew she was
maybe a minor. And he >> uh Porter Beller, I think you
doubt Tom Fury's power level. Okay. I think you seriously doubt
Tom's capability for saying something totally >> when Jada
slept with one friends. I thought that was cradle robbing. Then
Jaden told me about this destiny fellow and damn
dude. Okay. Uh
god damn it. Thank you very much Will Smith for the five. I thought
you were going to make a joke but from Tom. Tom talked about
let's get jiggy with it. I thought it was I thought that's where
the Will Smith donut was coming from. It had nothing to do with
it. I'm frankly disappointed a little bit. >> I really
wouldn't realize. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Oops. Wrong one. Wrong
>> So from this moment at the end of last year, he's potentially
mishandling
>> He has on Twitter and Hydra >> turned it into
the place. >> People posted those. >> He kept it
in his spank bank, right? And by the way, one of his constant
defenses is you guys are using this revenge of me and that's
so disgusting and how dare you. You know what's funny about that
is the whole reason these guys on Kiwi farms, by the way, when
Desi says that, when he says, "You're scrolling through and reading
my revenge," he means the DM leaks, by the way, which is totally
insane to bring up. When he leaked an illegally recorded conversation
with Denims to Willie for Willie Mack to put in a video, right?
When he leaked with Denims, when he leaked with Lauren de Lagona,
he leaks with all of these people and then says that's revenge.
So, is he a revenge? He is by his own measure, right?
>> To identify her is because Steven gave them the information.
He is the one that caused this whole thing. He said she went
to blank college.
>> Okay. And then they he shows a >> Ethan not reading
time stamps correctly. Okay. Ethan.
These read down here and then they read down and up. Okay. >> Picture.
If they want more to go on. It's funny because they think I'm
hiding stuff about Rose since she's underage. So, he already
says that these Kiwi Farm guys suspect she's underage. So, >> I
don't know. Why? Why didn't you just pull my tweet where I explained
to you how to read it, where I where I lay it all out for you.
Come on. >> This is already something people are thinking
about. The only reason I haven't actually mentioned much about
her is because I know it makes those rword words dig harder.
He continues, "Also, one more pick. I'm not in either one if
you can tell." Okay, good luck. Good luck, guys. So, he sent
them two pictures to go up. >> $5. Who do you think you
are? I'm not watching your stream, JSTLK. I'm Will Smith. I'm
too busy watching Jada get jiggy with someone else. >> Okay.
All right. Thank you, Will Smith, for the donos. I appreciate
it, buddy. That actually puts us over 45 for another hour on
the stream. Let's go. Let's go. Thank you very much, Will Smith,
for the kickbot donos. I assume that's like basically all the
same guy. But yeah, thank you. Thank you. Let me uh let me get
the kickbot stuff going. >> Also, I never said that. Let
me
It was a pic they sent me from their school. Supposedly, they
were working on an associates in neurology. Hi Farm's ability
to investigate anything is super pathetic. I thought it was some
crazy investigator, but now I realize it was just no life obsessively
stalking all my social media that allowed someone to do it. As
I understand it, this was the missing piece of the puzzle they
needed. And from learning seeing these photos he's shared with
them, from learning they that's how they identified her.
>> that is just by far the that's the juiciest point of
all of this story. If you're trying to tell a story that Destiny
for was so self-destructive
that he doxed the minor he was that he helped the people who
hate him most dox the minor he was proving she was a minor so
that he could actually realize the wrath of the wider internet
like how do you not that's that's like Shakespearean okay but
it's real life it's crazy after speaking with Willie Matt he's
told me that this is this is her right they found her they matched
up like moles on They matched up the look of her, the face, she
disappeared for a couple of years. They have old videos of her,
but they pretty much confirmed this is her. >> are the
denims recordings of a nature? No,
but they're are privacy violations. They're illegally recorded.
They're not of a nature. They are illegally recorded. So, it's
a privacy violation. Major privacy violation, right? But he did
release DMs with Denims and he is saying that Ethan Klein reading
his DMs is is reading through his revenge quote unquote. But
he does the same kind of revenge to other people by his own measure.
Through that they've identified her birthday and if this is her,
which is like 99% it is, then she was 17 at the time. No question.
Right. So, so this whole idea of is she's a minor has pretty
much already been put to rest according to Willie Mack. So, while
it's true that while when he received these nudes, he thought
she was 19, what is not true is that he didn't know the whole
time potentially because the boyfriend at the end of last year
told him she's a minor. So, he knew there was potentially a chance
that he had child. And up until now, when people found out she
actually is a minor, he never reported it to the police. any
responsible adult upon learning that even if there's a possibility
that you have child, you would send that to the police, right?
To hold and and frankly to to cover your own app legally, you
don't want to get you don't want to be stuck with child on your
hard drive. Like the second you find out, you send that [__]
to the authorities cuz guess what? You're committing a crime.
But that all becomes moot anyway because they've pretty they've
allegedly found out that Rose was a minor at the time and he
did hold child for 6 months allegedly and that's why he should
have turned it in to the authorities. >> $5. This Ethan
Klein guy is a member of my team just a little bit longer before
I'll be asking Steven Kenneth Bonnel I to have a seat. >> Why
don't you have a seat right over there? Why don't you have a
seat?
Stephen, we've got some very concerning DMs here. It seems like
you might have been aware that this girl was a minor in 2024.
Why don't you Why don't you have a seat right over there? Why
don't you have a seat right there? So, if you want to defend
Destiny,
do that. But know that this guy knew there was a chance that
he had child on his on his hard drive for all this time. He kept
it knowing that and did nothing with it. Now, if you think that's
cool and in the context of everything else of him continually
and trying to normalize
activity with minors, he has he's been doing this over the span
of his entire career. If you think that is fine and holding on
to potential child is fine, then go ahead and defend Destiny.
But just know that is what you're defending. Those are the facts,
Jack. >> I reported this to the police and recorded my
interactions and calls with the detective. Now, a lot of people
I say have been unfairly critical of Willie Mack for reporting
this to the police and immediately making a video on it. But
I have to say this guy did the absolute right thing. Somebody
told you they got shot on their computer. This is what Destiny
should have done 6 months ago. I think the reason is cuz he was
[__] from the beginning. You know, if in I think
if investigators look into this and get the DMs and the history
of all this stuff, >> I don't think Destiny was [__]
if Destiny went to the police immediately and said, "Hey, I have
reason to suspect that this could be child. Can you uh can you
hold all of this? I'm I need to get rid of all of this and he
like gave his computer his hard drives over and switched out
and did all this stuff, right? Then I don't know that he would
be totally here because he has probably plausible deniability.
As much as we don't necessarily believe him, okay, by his own
measure, he should have been way safer about this. But but by
the legal measure, I do believe that immediately informing the
police is an affirmative defense in cases of like child possession.
that as soon as you find out you you were in possession of child
or you have been right you notify the police immediately as soon
as you have suspicion he could be covered he could get out of
a lot of the more serious charges that would be laid sorry levied
at him so we'll see I guess as we come as we as this situation
comes to a head and and as this continues to develop we'll see
I guess >> there's they'll you will find out there's a
reason he didn't go directly to the police >> what a great
guy Destiny is a great guy >> that's crazy
>> at least he's not trying to get him laid because that
this guy just that would be insane. This guy is a deviant. >> Um,
this is obviously true. Porter Beller, I think a bunch of people
are concerned to say this. They think it seems unhinged to say
this. This is just obviously true. There's no reason to publish
that video on the internet except to preserve internet reputation.
Willie Mack absolutely put his internet reputation and his ties.
So Willie Mack's greatest nightmare is that he has to sit there
as as he lets these people investigate and then something gets
brought up and Destiny leaks his DMs with Willie Mack and says,
"I let Willie Mack know." And Willie Mack's career gets exploded.
Right. Willie Mack absolutely put the the investigation second,
his internet rep, his internet uh yeah, like credibility first.
Okay. Which is shocking because he didn't really seem to care
about his internet credibility that much when he was totally
maliciously lying about Queen, right? and me to a lesser extent,
but he said that that docs originated in Queen's community. That's
totally made up. That's a complete lie, right? He didn't really
care about his rep back then. So, it's interesting that here
he's he's trying to recover something. I don't know. And burning
Destiny cuz that is the major association that he had to get
rid of, right? He had just taken Destiny had basically laid it
out for everybody, right? Hey, this Willy Mack guy like totally
totally put my narrative about Queen and Jtock in his video and
here I'm going to read my DMs proving it to you. And then he
went on to do other stuff.
And so I guess Willie Mack felt like, "Oh well, I have to disassociate
pretty strongly here." >> And and this guy should just
abstain from the rest of his life. >> If Destiny was my
roommate, I get him laid all the time. >> Come on, bro.
>> What? You said that? >> I don't Mhm. >> That
was you? >> I don't know. >> Holy [__]
That's stunning. I don't know why that's what >> that was
my that's my take on it. So just to do a recap, yes, two of the
screenshots I shared were not with Rose. Two of the three. However,
don't let people gas or or distract you into thinking that that
even matters. What matters is Destiny's confession on record
to Willie Mack when he was asked three times very clearly if
he had child if he potentially had child on his computer. And
he answered in the affirmative every time. He said yes s yes.
He knew that it might be child as early as November of last year.
In that six months leading up to now, he never reported it to
the authorities. He never made any effort to handle it responsibly.
Those are the relevant facts. It's just boom boom boom. >> We'll
see. Cyber Drifter, we'll see. >> Listen, the guy's a creep.
He's a degenerate. There's no other way to cut it. If you if
you like Destiny, if you think he's smart and cool and funny
and awesome, good. Keep watching him. know that you are supporting
someone who has attracted 15-year-olds, who shares compromising
bikini pics a 15-year-old sent to him with his boys. He has held
on knowing there's a chance of child for 6 months and never reported
it to the authorities. That he assaulted a woman on camera. You
want to come at me and say, "Oh, you got all this thing wrong.
>> those are those are good points. I missed the first
15year-olds who shared compromising bikini pics a 15-year-old
sent to him with his boys. He has >> it's the same two
points. >> Hold on knowing there's a chance for six months
and never reported it to the authorities that he assaulted a
woman on >> You want to come at me and say, "Oh, you got
all this thing wrong. You're gas lit and you're lying all this
shit." Bro, uncontroversial facts. You are up to defend this
guy and like I guess I don't know if you're being gaslit or misled,
but like watching the video that Abba made with all of this context
out here and he he's accusing me of not doing research. Abba,
why did you brush over the screenshot of him confessing
to knowingly having potential child on his hard drive? >> If
Abba did not take that seriously, I don't know. I don't know
what to say. That would be very goofy. >> Never commented
on that. You only commented on things that I got wrong. Right.
Ignore the whole context. You're sweeping for a what looks to
me to be a
long-term, highly motivated, premeditated child predator. That's
what he looks like to me. He's got a long history of it. So,
if you want to sweep for the boy, then good. You want to put
your flag down on that hill, that's okay. If you want to die
on Lolly Hill with the rest of them, that's okay. But just know
where you are resting your flag. And with that, I say to all
the naysayers and all the haters out there who have said that
I need to apologize and for getting things wrong. Well, I did
apologize for getting the screenshots, but to you guys, I say
you suck my unsubscribe and go support this weirdo creep potential.
And Destiny, you're this big man that's willing to be um transparent
about everything. Do me a favor. Just watch this video. Watch
this whole video with your fans on stream. Abba, watch this whole
video on stream with your fans. Show me how brave and just all
knowing you are and how unscared of this you are. Go ahead and
do that and explain to us everything I've mentioned here. I'll
see you next time. Wow. Okay. So, yeah, I'm guessing on the actual
criticisms, there's going to be very light commentary. I I've
heard that Ethan Klein's got some bad clips here, and I'm I'm
guessing that's going to be a lot of this. Okay. Listen, guys.
I might have, this is Destiny impression, by the way. This is
not an actual code for me. This is a Destiny impression. But
he's going to say something like, "Listen, I might have uh multiple
videos on my on some hard drive I own. I might do that. But you
know what, Ethan? You've made jokes, too. And isn't that the
real crime here? The joking about Isn't that the real crime,
Ethan?" And I'm guessing a lot of his fans will fall for that
because they are the lowest IQ,
least morally righteous people that exist on planet Earth. But,
you know, sorry, that exists in this internet sphere, I should
say. Probably not on planet Earth. I'm sure there's like uh actual,
you know, child traffickers and stuff, but in this sphere for
sure. That was it. That was it. That was it for his video. Okay,
we will get to the Destiny reaction, the Destiny response shortly.
Very shortly, in fact, right after this. Okay, so from here,
all right, from
what do I want to I want to do chill and then I think we go right
into the next video. J talk needs to learn that clips are at
minimum 15 seconds. So he needs the clarification on both sides.
Oh, true. Yeah, true. All right,
but whatever. People want to. It's funny. Okay,
guys. If you like the content, follow on every platform. Follow
on Twitter. Follow on twitch. twitch.tv/jdlk
with an
All right.
If you really like the content, go ahead, sub. Throw up some
gift subs. Donate.
Sub. Sub to the Patreon, patreon.com/jstk.
All right, patreon.com/jastk.
Every donation method except for the Patreon goes directly towards
more time on the stream. Don't forget to throw your Twitch primers,
guys, on the Twitch channel. All right, check if your Twitch
primer is available. Throw it at me. Really appreciate the Twitch
primers as well. Okay, couple different tiers on the Patreon.
All right, $5 tier, $15 tier, $25 tier, $100 tier. Don't sign
up for the $100 tier unless you make at least six figures a year.
Okay, you need to be rolling in dough to sign up for the $100
tier.
But do sign up for the Patreon, guys. I do appreciate all of
the support. I do appreciate having people on another platform
where they have like recurring charges. If you can only pick
one, pick the Patreon. Okay? If you can only pick one, pick the
Patreon. When's the last time you did an oiler call? Those guys
are getting ripped off. Somebody banned Dung Devil right now.
Uh, I do calls all the time, Dung Devil. What are you talking
about? Those happen all the time. Literally all the time. All
right. Okay. Where are we going? We're going to the finally the
Destiny reaction. Okay. What? Everybody really wanted to be here.
And we're only 9 minutes behind, guys. I said I wanted to hit
the Destiny reaction as we were hitting our like our previously
normal start time of 7:30. And we are right there. We're right
on the money.
We're right there. Let's go. I believe this is the time stamp.
We'll see if we'll see if I got an accurate time stamp. Okay.
>> Oh, look. He's got all three chats going right now.
>> Four hours watching
this god awful video
>> for four hours watching a 30 minute video. What?
What? What? What?
Hold on. Wait, what? >> Welcome back, guys, to another
video.
>> This a 35minute video that you spent four hours watching,
apparently.
Interesting. Interesting. >> Welcome back. >> He
said last night he prepped for 5 hours. I sure hope he's got
ways to explain the actual problems, right? I I hope so, but
it'd be hard to know. I will remind you guys, okay, that Destiny
did point out there's a there's a couple funny things, you know,
maybe real quick before we run this. Maybe I'll run. You remember
when Ethan reacted to it
>> like right off the bat and uh and Desessie pointed out
how to be humble. All right. I do think highly of myself. All right.
Especially when it comes to responding to things, politics, whatever
the else. Okay. I don't think even I would watch that a video
like that live. I think I would review the video offline first.
Like I watched the whole Ryan Beard video offline and then I'm
thinking about like that's awesome that What was this? This is
May 3rd. This is more than 3 months ago. He watched the whole
Ryan Beer video offline as you responded to the Ryan Beer video
or
did he do a response? Maybe I missed the
Maybe I just totally missed it.
>> The fact that that content cop I think it dropped live
and then I think Ethan watched it I think on the same stream.
That's insane. Okay, that's a that is a incredibly
brave okay set of action for Ethan to take there. that shows
an ungodly amount of confidence in his >> Uh, the H3 video
is not a proxy of the Ryan Beard video. The H3 video is garbage
in comparison. Is not a tight narrative at all. The idea that
it's a proxy of the Ryan Beard video. Like Ryan Beard's point
was this guy [__] kids, that's insane. That's not
even remotely a proxy for the Ryan Beard video. Ryan Beard video
is about a a long-term pattern of behavior of engaging in deviency
and then using his har his platform as a vehicle for harassment
towards people to make them shut up and leave when he's a total
when he's a total [__] psychopath to them, right?
It is a long-term pattern of behavior. Uh Ethan didn't deliver
any of that at >> position for him to do that. I don't
think I would have done that. That's wild. Um but Jesus >> I
just don't think I feel like you're going to get really emotional
and say something you regret. Well, I've got the >> Like,
I know you you don't have a problem taking a head. >> Also,
I want to say this as well. And part of this is from jealousy,
I guess. >> I wanted I wanted this part here right now.
I wanted this part here cuz this is very funny given a couple
days ago what Destiny was saying about the H3 crew. Okay, just
a very funny quote I noticed when I was looking for some stuff
today. Also, I want to say this as well, and part of this is
from jealousy, I guess, but major props to Dan and all of the
crew, by the way, that have stuck by Ethan with Ethan through
all of this because they are getting a lot of pressure external.
Wow, it sure sounds like he knows who that Dan guy is.
He's literally calling Dan out by name without knowing Dan's
name, okay? And saying, "Dude, you guys are doing great work.
You're withstanding a lot of pressure. I know things are really
tough on you right now, okay? I know things are hard, but listen,
Dan, I know it's not it's today. So, two days ago, it was I don't
even know who this Dan guy is. I don't even know who any of these
people are. I don't even know who Dan's name cuz he's I've got
a Dan on my stream. But here, he's like giving Dan props for
all the he's doing. Amazing how he can just totally forget this
guy. You don't see it. You probably don't even see a tenth of
the insane amounts of crazy unhined weird DM.